I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry
shy
No, don't be shy, they love you, I love you
Yeah, I love you
Welcome to Ohio
Welcome to the stream, can you guys hear my funny bunny?
Ah, I'm your funny bunny, oh my God
I'm not ready for this.
I'm basically literally only good as Serenity's low.
That's for your protection.
Serenity's a little quiet.
Hold on.
I'm going to bump you on.
It looks like on the edge.
On.
There we go.
You're, you're, you're.
Whee!
Better on.
Is this, is this loud enough?
Or is it too loud now?
I'm going to bump you up on, um,
on what do you call it?
Discord.
I'm hot in the moon.
Something, something, something on a summer afternoon.
Something, something.
I don't remember the rest of the song.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I think this is good.
Maybe a little bit more.
I can get closer.
I can get closer to the, hold on.
Hey, little mama, let me just burn your ear.
Let me tell you something you'd really like to hear.
How's that?
How's that sound?
Tackle yackies a bit loud?
Hold on.
Let's turn down the tackles of the yackies.
It does have like a bang and bang and, uh, OTS.
OST?
Oh my God.
OST.
Original soundtrack.
Anyways, we wanted to ask you snippets and,
and sweetie buns a question.
Oh, this is really important.
Genuinely, like very important.
We need to, I, we both need to know,
I need to know a little bit more.
Mercy was pretty satisfied with what we came up with,
but I was like, should we, should we ask?
Yeah, we need to ask.
Okay, okay.
Well, Serenity, you may go first.
I, I, I, I, I, I, I was ready to leave, but,
I simply wanted to ask a question about,
our sweater puppies.
Yeah, our puppies.
Who's bigger?
Hahaha!
Hahahahaha!
Where are these things I'm bigger?
I don't know!
Hahahaha!
Why?
I think you're bigger.
See they're saying serenity.
Hahaha!
Now hold on!
Hold on!
Miku over here!
I think that's it!
Hahaha!
Oopsie!
Ahahaha!
I see Serenity out, out, out doing.
Ha ha!
Hee hee hee hee hee!
Hmm.
This sounds like a trap?
No, it's like genuine, it's genuine.
We just need to know so we can,
so we can like buy, buy matching t-shirts.
Yeah.
Oh, I was gonna say, oh, okay.
I was gonna say like, you know,
in case we have to like share bras or something,
like, you know, you gotta know.
We have to know.
Yeah, we have to know.
What if we wanted to like, swap swimsuits?
Have you ever gotten like a pair of a bikini?
A very relatable story.
Buying bikini tops and be like,
oh, this one's cute, but those bottoms aren't.
Like, you just mix and match.
Very relatable to the snippets, right?
Hee hee hee hee!
Yeah, I feel like, I feel like definitely
for like, clothing size, we should get like a large,
so that both of us can like wear.
Or maybe an extra large for those puppies.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha!
Hee hee hee hee hee hee hee!
These fuckin' marmajokes.
Hee hee hee hee hee hee!
Yeah, yeah?
Hee hee hee hee hee hee hee hee hee.
But anyways, Senpai, meet my bestie,
Serenity Cosmic Cat from VNU.
Oh no!
Hello, hi, I'm SerenityqualS構,
your favorite girlie pop bunny girlie pop
bunny girlvie in your generation
5thfullyclub and I love sweetie!
Hee hee hee hee hee hee hee hee hee hee hee hee hee hee hee hee hee hee hee hee hee heehe de ist.
Hee hee hee hee hee hee hee hee heee hee hee hee hee hee hee hee hee heeee hee
I'm so happy.
We've been so looking forward to this.
I think the senpais are super looking forward to this,
but I have been like looking forward to this
since like you got into the VNU.
I've been looking forward to this forever.
Yeah, I don't like legit ever since getting into VNU.
I've been like first thing, first thing I wanted to,
boop, boop, I'm like punching the air.
I'm like the guy at like like the guy
who's like leaning down the box.
He's like, I'm gonna be so fucking good at hugging.
That's me.
I'm gonna be like, I'm gonna be so good,
ready for that Mercy Collapse.
Uh-uh.
Like we were so happy together when I,
when you got into VNU, I was like, I had you on
five monitors.
I had you on the big TV.
I had you on my phone.
I had you on my iPad.
I had you on both of my monitors.
Sweetie Buns know how embarrassing I've been for like,
like I have been a public nuisance.
I mean, I feel like, like we saw the watch along.
We, I cried.
I cried on your debut.
Fuck it.
Oh my God.
I was like, I was trying so hard to keep it together
because I was like, no guys, it's totally normal right now.
I'm just really like me in the midst.
I'm just so like losing it
that I like immediately text you after.
I was like, ahhh.
Hold on.
They're reminding me to say I'm live.
I forgot to do that.
No, no, no, no, no.
What are you talking about?
Snippets don't have, they don't ring that fucking bell.
Snippets don't click notify me
when a Mercy's seen this one.
You guys don't do that.
Mercy's perfect.
You guys are the problem.
Hahaha.
Hold on, I'll do it.
I'll do it.
I got it.
Don't worry, I have my Twitter's open.
Dead Name This app forever.
Live with.
Just a moment.
30 minutes, Ailee.
Good.
That's Sampai.
He's got the stamp of approval.
The stamp of approval.
That's Sampai.
Thumbs up.
He can propose.
Hahaha.
I just have two lines set.
Look at these Sampais.
Look at these guys.
They're so loyal.
These wonderful, upstanding gentlemen.
Good boys.
Look at boys.
I'm so proud of you.
You're making me look good in front of Serenity.
That's great.
Hahaha.
Hold on, I got this.
Wait, Ting.
We can't leave.
Hahaha.
Why would you want to leave a Macy stream though?
You don't want to be here forever?
You guys always act like,
oh, I don't want to be in the basement.
I don't want to be in the basement.
Why not?
What's the problem here, officer?
You don't want a pumpkin bag?
You don't want the cutest waifu in town?
Are you kidding me?
I'm gonna be wrinkled.
Sounds like you need to spend more time in the basement.
Clearly you don't know the fucking privileges you have here.
It's so funny.
It's so funny because she's like,
she was like,
they need to pick out a bang and ring out help them.
Once we get married.
I'm begging.
Like, Sampais, I, you gotta like,
like I'm the one you call
if you need help picking out Mercy's ring
for when you're proposed to her.
I, I'm so sorry, I'm kind of like,
of course I understand, you're her Sampai,
like you get it, but like,
I don't know if I can trust you guys
picking out the perfect ring for her.
She's my bestie, you know?
Like, you need a second opinion.
I'm having so much fun.
I'm having so much fun right now.
This is so fun.
We haven't even started playing yet.
Okay, hold on Sampais.
We're gonna have to, oh, what's the word?
I'm gonna have to turn Pakoyaki party off for a second
so we can do the cold.
You know, you know the cold, right?
Good.
Okay, I'm connecting to a server.
Oh, it saves our progress.
It does?
Damn, we started playing and I were like,
wait, we should stop.
We had to test the game with the cold.
Come on.
Okay, no, we gotta go.
We look so good.
Don't worry, the batter is vegan.
Everything else is not.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, don't worry.
There are no eggs have been used in this batter.
No eggs allowed.
However, Mercy did come to me with a very important rule.
So if you can notice in the corner of the screen,
we do have to do squat.
So whenever we will, oh God, oh God, I have to eat.
I'm dying, I'm out.
I'm gonna die, I'm gonna die, I'm out.
Oh, we gotta do this now.
I'm not gonna eat, I'm a hungry girl.
I'm hungry, I don't even have fiber sauce.
I have no time for sauce, I just gotta go.
Other one, we're gonna die.
Look at these sauce.
Munch, munch, munch, munch, munch, munch.
Oh, I'm overeating, hold on,
we gotta do real squats in real life.
Oh, don't eat, don't eat, don't eat, don't eat, don't eat.
Okay, okay, okay, okay, I've squatted, I've squatted.
No, one squat each time.
Wait, is it, okay, I was squatting with the guy.
Is it only one squat per?
We can just like keep going.
Okay, okay.
You guys get dinner and a show, you're welcome.
We're so good.
Oh, I'm so bad at this.
No, you're perfect.
You make the best takoyaki, are you kidding?
Oh, I forgot to eat these once.
Oh, good.
That's how good your takoyaki is,
it's so good that you're like, oh man,
I can't even remember if I ate it or not yet.
One, two.
Shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh,
shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh, shh,
munch, munch, oh shit.
Ah!
Oh, god, yes it is, it's very bad to run out of protein.
Oh, hold on, I'm sorry, I'll squatter.
Oh, shit, shit, shit, shit, shit, shit, shit.
Okay, I cannot sit at crisscross applesauce today.
Oh, oh, oh, applesauce today.
This is one, two, three, four.
Okay, I need to eat protein or I'm gonna fucking die.
No, you're not gonna get squatter!
I'm gonna get squatter!
Oh, no!
We have to squat or else we're gonna die.
Look at how many days we've been alive.
We're only for the live shooting!
Oh my legs!
No, it's so fine. It's so fine.
Can I get anything but cheese?
Can I get anything?
I need meat!
I need beef!
Give me the beef!
No beef for you!
You lover!
Girl, I'm gonna...
Give me...
That sausage isn't enough.
Sausages aren't enough.
Even now, the sausage...
Oh shit!
Don't die!
Give me that sausage!
Give me the yummy sausage!
Yumtown USA over here!
And we're going to be doing it today!
I'm in pain!
Yeah, me too!
Okay, I'm gonna add the sauce.
Oh, wait a minute!
Okay!
One!
Oh shit!
Oh!
One!
Oh shit!
I'm going with the guy!
Okay, okay, okay!
Senpai!
This really hurts!
Yo, Senpai, what the fuck?
Why is it always cheese?
I know! I don't eat cheese!
I have too much fat!
God, I wish I had...
I'm gonna fucking die!
I'm like fucking...
Okay, one!
Okay, okay!
One!
I'm malnutrition and I'm...
Two!
Oh my god!
Start pouring the batter in!
I don't like...
We're not things we wanted to talk about!
Shit!
We had things we wanted to talk about!
I was like, oh!
I have to save these like...
Stories for stream, huh?
I should...
I should save...
But now we're in panic mode!
Oh god!
Oh god, oh god, oh god!
Okay, okay!
There's no time!
Anyways, Senpai!
Ah, my protein!
Don't die!
Okay!
Isn't it cool?
That I'm gonna die!
Isn't that so cool?
Let me see your eyes!
Oh, you bitch!
This is not cool!
My princess needs it!
We love each other!
Oh god!
Grab some on this side,
if you need more protein!
Thank you!
On this side?
I'm eating!
Oh, I'm full, I'm full, I can...
I don't think I need to bake!
So anyways, Senpai,
don't you think it's like really cool?
I'm gonna fuck you!
Malnutrition?
Oh fuck!
Oh no!
Goodbye, goodbye world!
Oh no, she's fucking dead!
Oh my god, I lived, bitch!
Okay, what?
I died!
Oh no, play her dead!
We're getting...
We're back in it, baby!
And I can eat so much takoyaki right now!
Yum, yum, yum!
Here, I'll eat this bad one over here too, yummy!
Malnutrition already!
Oh, beef?
Okay, you know, mercy,
I'm not gonna lie,
it's kind of good dying.
Dying was kind of a good choice.
Dying was a good choice?
Words I never expected to hear.
Oh shit!
Goodbye!
Was it the protein?
I need the protein!
I got you, I got you, I got you!
I said I'm overeating though!
We got, we got four steaks cooking!
Okay, these are steaks,
I can't give it to you?
No!
Oh god, I gotta eat.
I'm so upset!
Goodbye!
No!
This game is cruel!
We might not,
we might have to not do squats,
I'm already tired!
I might have to not do squats!
I'm determined though,
I'm gonna keep doing it!
You're gonna keep doing it?
Okay, I don't know,
it's okay!
I'll do it,
I'll do it with you!
You know,
I'll ask the senpai,
senpai,
did you want us to keep doing squats,
or is the answer not what we like?
Not what we like!
Maybe senpais will be like,
oh my god, no mercy,
your legs are tired,
we love you!
Don't make morning noises
in the mic, fra!
No, for what?
No!
What kind of thing
senpai would want that?
Wow!
I had to be,
I told them to behave around you,
and then look at you!
Look at you!
You said behave around me,
and then I DM'd you saying,
hey, is it okay if I say,
mods circumcised?
I've been telling them,
that like,
it's like, hey,
it's like,
mods obliterate his destes!
Mods,
make his foreskin away,
he doesn't get the extra pocket now.
You look like you shouldn't
be wearing a dress like this today,
hold on.
Whoa!
Gotta wait 18 seconds for this.
I feel my neck is so sweaty right now.
Man, I have no protein!
Here, I'll take the nasty ones.
Don't worry,
I'll put proteins
kinda near you-ish.
There you go.
Remember you.
Anyway!
Surprise!
What are-
Oh, shit, man,
I've lost all the fun stories
I wanted to talk about.
I'm like,
oh, I remember!
When I texted you,
right before the,
your designs got
announced,
when you guys were still
little silhouettes,
I remember,
when I messaged you,
cause I was like,
ugh, what was your nickname?
Stabs.
Stabs!
Yeah!
I was like,
I hope stabs is like,
a seamstress.
Cause I'm like,
I want you to make clothes.
Again?
Can I stop getting my city bill?
Oh god, I got a squat.
I got a squat.
This is painful!
This is what I'm feeling right now.
Okay.
No, so, always overeating.
This is too much calories.
It really is.
This isn't healthy.
This isn't,
for the amount of squats we're doing in between,
this is not a healthy amount of food.
This is like,
we're doing so much squats,
and I feel like I'm dying.
I don't care if I'm gonna overeat.
I gotta eat it!
I gotta eat this!
Have you ever gone to like,
a KVDQ place,
and like an,
oh you can eat buffet,
where they charge you
if you don't finish?
Oh yeah!
And then they give you extra,
because they're,
they're so rude.
I am!
Oh my god.
Oh my,
cause it doesn't even give us enough.
It doesn't give us enough to eat all.
Okay.
The music suddenly changed to,
10 Ho Ten Gay.
It changed.
It was so fun before.
It was like a fun piano.
And now,
now it's just pain.
Now it's just sweating.
It's like the beginning
of like 10 Ho Ten Gay,
where it's like,
I'm like sweating.
It's like we're here.
I feel hot.
I gotta take off these slippers.
What?
No.
Three.
Four.
Okay.
It's like four,
four squats per thing.
I can do that.
I can do four squats.
Fuck.
Anyway, so have you been today, Macy?
It's okay.
I was literally,
my mind was nothing,
but to like today,
I was like,
I can't do anything else.
Everything today,
revolves around,
my funny bunny.
I'm so excited
for today.
I've been looking for it
since your debut.
I'm so happy
we're playing this game
because it looked really fun.
It's a good time.
I'm fucking sweating.
You too?
Me too.
I hope I better like,
lose like,
at least a pound.
Oh my God,
definitely at least.
Cause like,
it's like every 18 seconds,
cause like,
one,
two,
three,
four.
Okay.
Oh God.
All the way down.
Oh.
I need to stop eating cucumbers.
That's my problem.
I'm just fully standing now.
I'm just fully,
I'm just fully standing.
I'm just standing now.
This is,
this is no longer a stream.
This is business.
Oh no, it's burning.
It's burning.
Or,
okay, okay, okay.
This is business.
God damn it.
Another cucumber.
God, it's like the cucumbers are,
are big.
They're, they're meant,
they're meant to ruin us.
Give us meat.
More meat.
Can I just like,
toss this away?
Yeah.
Fuck this.
Fuck this cheese.
Look at this cheese out of here.
Give me the beef.
Here's more beef.
We need it.
We need all the beef.
This can be gross.
Actually that is sparkling.
Does that mean I have that?
I'm gonna die.
Oh my God, I'm out of fat.
I'm out of fat.
I'm out of,
oh my God.
No, no, no.
Okay.
Eat you.
And I put favorite candy.
That's not,
that's not enough.
Oh my God.
My protein is so low.
I, I'm,
this is it.
This is it for me.
And I'm overeaten.
No, goodbye.
Goodbye.
I have no protein,
no fat,
I'm nothing.
Goodbye.
Player dead.
This is,
this is it.
This is what you were playing for.
This is the relief.
My legs are chilly.
I sat down again.
Fuck.
Guys,
you don't know how dangerous it is to eat takoyaki
until you're right there in the fucking pit.
Until God is looking you in the eyes
and all you could say is more, please.
Give me another cucumber.
Where's the beef?
You don't know real pain.
You don't know real pain and suffering
until you've been faced with the takoyaki gods
and you've been told
you four squats per 18 seconds.
And what are you going to do?
Say no.
We live and die by our takoyaki gods.
We live and die by the takoyaki gods.
We cannot deny them.
Oh, no.
My imminent death.
Oh, wait, no.
We're good.
We'll go dribble off to that sweet good night.
Oh, wait.
There's emails.
I didn't realize.
Oh, shit.
Yeah.
Me when I met you.
I'm going to fucking die.
No.
No, you're too sexy.
Don't die.
You're too sexy.
You can't die.
No.
Can I just drop these?
I can.
Yeah, fuck these little balls.
Get these balls out of here.
Girl, are you still alive?
No.
Oh.
Well, there goes the balls.
I don't know how you're still alive.
No, it's barely holding on.
I'm proud of you.
Survive, baby cakes.
Barely holding on.
The last beef.
One, two, three.
Oh, God.
Oh, my legs are getting shaky.
Oh, I'm entering shaky zone of the squat.
Of the squatathon.
Come on.
Ah, fuck, I died.
No.
Drink time.
Yeah.
Oh, my God.
This is the only time we get a break here.
Honestly.
It's the only time that we have a chance to breathe.
I'm...
Okay.
Back in the game, baby.
I feel like I have so much.
Oh, my God, I've eaten a hundred takoyaki.
It tells you how many?
I got an achievement.
It's like, congratulations, eater.
Oh, my God.
I can't just say that to somebody.
Day two.
This is when I die.
Oh, God.
Okay.
Let me do some squats real fine.
It's all time.
Oh, never mind.
300 calories already gone.
Grab those two.
God.
I just...
I don't get how they're like, yeah, this is easy.
What's the most...
Wasn't this suggested by your manager?
We're already out of breath and coughing.
Your lungs out?
Yeah.
Professor Hamstein was like, hey, serenity.
Do you know that we are really fun to game for you?
And I'm like, oh, boy, Professor Hamstein, why?
Oh, boy.
Oh, boy, what is it?
Oh.
You're squatting again.
I'm squatting.
I can't do it.
No.
I ate 100 chocolate yaki.
I got the...
I got it.
No, they're all burned.
I'll take some.
Oh, they're all burnt.
Just pause it.
I have to...
I think I have to strip.
Yeah.
Oh, my God.
Girl, me too.
I'm ready.
Girl, I'm like...
Now we're gaming.
Okay.
I'm wearing a workout shirt.
Out.
I have my elbow on my closet.
Okay.
I'm ready.
My entire back is like a freaking swamp.
It's fucking business now.
This isn't a game anymore.
This is business, guys.
This is business snippets.
You guys don't understand.
This is what happens.
We're like, yeah, we're going to do squats with the game.
What a foolish idea.
When you take two girls who commit to the bit too hard,
and we're like, yeah, yeah, we'll do squats.
What?
Like it's hard?
Oh, this is so much better.
Okay.
Yeah.
I feel the breeze.
Oh, my God.
It's like I was wearing just like my nightgown.
That was a mistake.
Yeah.
Yeah, no.
I was like, I have this like cute like dress I've been trying out.
And I was like, oh yeah, this dress, it's fine.
I'm in my cozy.
My cozy alleys.
No, it's business now.
It's business now.
This is survival.
Oh, shit.
I'm running out of protein again.
I'm like that one guy from home sweet home.
Protein protein protein.
Okay.
I'm like hitting the like squat button because I'm waiting for the squat to come back.
I know.
I know I should be doing that too.
You know, I should just be actively squatting.
Is that a peppermint takoyaki?
I think we're supposed to like eat them to like shit.
I dropped that one.
Oh, shit.
Fuck.
Drop it.
Drop this.
Eat.
There we go.
Okay.
Grab you guys.
I know.
I know I'm dying.
What do you want from me?
I swear.
If we're going to get demonetized for exercising, that would be hilarious.
That'd be so fucked up.
All we're doing is we're just girly things.
Oh, oh, you.
Now my back is numb.
No.
I go outside, but not that much.
Please, please, please.
One, two, three.
I'm committing to the death.
Four.
Okay.
Eat.
Oh, I'm going to fucking die.
No.
No, baby.
It's a sexy.
Don't die.
Can you extra beef?
Do you need protein?
You need fat.
Oh, cheese.
Beef.
Beef and fat.
Fat.
Cheese.
I'm going to say it.
Why did I eat cucumber?
No.
Octopus.
Oh, God.
It's over for me too, Bab.
It's over.
We can't think about suffering.
It's fucking over.
Ugh, wait, I'm still alive somehow.
Don't die.
You're so pretty.
You're so sexy.
Baby, you're so sexy.
You're my Oshii.
That's when that's when it's your oh she but you're cool like that, you know
Just asking
Oh
He's so fun
And I guess that means I'm a certain type of archetype
I died
Like I don't know I'd describe myself as like
I'm your fun cringe bunny
There's so much beef there's so much beef baby there's so much beef and cheese
Thank you for the beef and cheese I appreciate I appreciate it
Eat the balls
Oh
My baby can't breathe she you could say that she's breathless
I'm over here taking my hand and you're making jokes. You make a joke. It's called Drizzling. Thank you
My skippity got
My skippity got after this damn
I'll be brain rot you want brain rot? I'll give you brain rot. What's the sigma?
Oh
Just just take your asthma take your
Take your your
Take your asthma, I think I'm done now I
Can't commit to this bit
Can't I you know I can't do it
Now we can actually chat
I
Like mama didn't raise a squitter yes, she did
Quite the quitter mama told me if you need a quit fucking quit
Your limits and I said yes, ma'am mama said you suck at the stop it
You
Can have my sausage me saying it like the absolute creep I am
Thank you
Die for the sausage
Would kill me. I'm just privileged enough to eat it
You know how YouTube's been having like these like fucking
Descriptions like auto-generate
I want to know what the chat description for this one is right now
What what what have the snippets been saying I I will not wow I've been a very bad bunny
I have not looked over at the snippets in a minute. I'm very sorry snippets. I love you guys or sometimes
Snippets are sometimes both are interchangeable. Don't worry about it. They're like synonyms, baby
Snippets you guys are very cute. I'm very sorry. I'm trying. I'm trying hard to feed mercy. You try to make sure mercy doesn't die either
I think I'm good for now
The summary says we're floating
That's right
Take a guess where I get my wrist from
What
Actually, I got it from you I meant to say I got it from you
I'm trying to
You know what never mind
No, no, you know we try to make something a little jealous
Kissing your bestie and then I'm dying never mind. It's like watching your bestie die
You know that's very relatable it's like
You know, it's it's a cute. Well, I can't say it's like of uh
Uh uh uh uh
An introduction date where like, you know, I get to meet your senpais and it's like, oh my gosh. Hi
Because like this is a pretty rough introduction for me. I'm over here fucking sweating bullet
We're both sweating. We're just like here meet my new meet my new partner
I fucking died
It's like, oh my god, meet my new partner the senpais. I'm like, hi
I just fucking died
You fucking collapse onto the fucking table
Okay, eat all of that up
What the sigma what the skibbity?
Skibby toilet skibby fortnite riz
I've been watching deep analytical videos about the war to skibby toilet
That's so funny
Hey
There's more there's more that's inflated
Honestly, I was not I was surprised that skibbity toilet had
Lore there's like a war and time
Giants
Yeah
It's an interesting deconstruction on oh my gosh. She's the deconstruction
On how we're so tied to a screen
Oh god
I'm gonna die. Oh wait, I need to do this squash
I'm gonna eat this this peppermint
No, you have the peppermint. I want the peppermint
Yeah, eat the peppermint. Oh, I'm cooking another peppermint for you. Thank you
What about the peppermint does?
Well, we have like a billion up in the corner
Like maybe we win if we eat it. Oh my god. Oh my god
We win
Oh god
I'm fucking dying. Goodbye. Goodbye
We I've only made it to
Get your peppermint. I don't remember which one it was. I don't know either. We're just gonna
Skibbity
No
You get so much calories what the heck
I know
Like I get it. It's a bunch of bread
But like we barely got any carbs
Oh my god, I feel like I'm on like
Like I'm I'm still like cooling down from doing so many squats. I don't even I wasn't even keeping count
I was just squatting like every moment was just a squat squat squat
I was trying I was trying to keep up mom tired now. We're tired. We're girl failures
No, we're girl winners. We can't let the sweetie buns know they can't they really want me to be a girl failure
I refuse. What are you talking about? She actually accomplishes so much
She can't be a failure if you accomplish it so much
You're not a failure either. Are you kidding me? Girl success over here
Girl success
I'll hear from all of us. All of us sometimes
All of you sometimes
She can't know she can't know I'm secretly a senpai guys
Is that what you're in the basement all the time?
It's like I'm wearing a little mask. It's barely hidden. It's barely hidden. I'll be like, oh, shit. Who's this?
Take off the mask serenity cosmica from v and u
It's like it's like those fucking groucho glasses with like the big nose and the mustache
And I'm like, hello. I'm
Karenadine
Wait, what? Oh, no, shit nuts nuts nuts. Why can't I do nothing?
I
I'm still tired from the squats and I haven't been squatting yet
I'm just your average Saturday morning cartoon villain
I'm at zero day, sweetie
Maybe we win if we get like all three can all the candies up there. Oh, maybe maybe
I don't know if we can win. I'll be honest. I don't think there's a winner into this game. I just think we're all losers
I think I think we lost the moment we played
That's
That's so grim
We're like coughing so much because we're like exhausted
Wait, I'll take the burnt ones. Don't worry. I like the flavor
I'm trying to get ourselves another peppie mint
I know my god, my god. I'm just I need 200 tokyaki. Nothing can stop me. I'm unstoppable feed me more
I say yummy yummy yummy get in my tummy. Thank you
Oh my god, I say I'm on the brink of death no matter what I do
No matter how
Oh
God it really is give us freedom freedom give us a peppermint
Bless you
Oh cute sneezes
You've always loved your sneezes
I love you
I don't love these squads no
Oh
How how perfect for a first collab, you know nothing like a cute date with a bestie going to like
Why you can eat takoyaki where your life is
Where life is on the line
And you're seeing stars and you're sweating non-stop sweating just buckets
And you don't know what to do and you're open out coughing and
Ah
You keep eating cucumbers
No
It's my cucumbers are evil cucumbers are evil. Why would we eat cucumbers?
Nothing good. I'm about to toss some of these
Never mind. I'm gonna toss my I ate meat
I ate meat
Oh no, she's
She's fucking dead
There are so many ingredients
Mercy
Yes, mercy. Yes, we haven't gotten any new ingredients because we have to survive more days
In order to get more ingredients
How the fuck are we supposed to survive?
I don't know
I think we can't egg max. Oh wait, but we can't egg's evil egg is evil
Let me let me eat. Let me eat everything. Let me eat my piggy fill
I'll eat all the eggs. Don't worry. I won't let them touch you
Get away from her
Get behind me queen get behind me
Shh
God the squats is crazy squats is actually crazy like
What a fun game that we get to play wow
Oh, shit
I mean maybe but what you want to see dry dry balls like this
You want us dry balls? We need we need our fat
Ha my voice cracked
We need we need the extra fat are you kidding every calorie counts
I'm trying
Okay, I think I think I think we need a strat
We need a strategy
I don't even know what you guys are good for
We need a strategy and the strategy isn't squat squat squat squat squat
No, but squatting is important. I think we got to be squatting
We have to eat
Oh, that was nothing
and then
We don't
We don't we don't flip all of them. We only flip the ones we need
They don't burn while they're like still batter, right? Yeah. Yeah, they don't burn while they're batter
So I feel like if we just do what we need
And we squat often because our calories our calories are killing us
Our calories and our fat and protein are killing us
Yeah
fat and protein are really fucking us over but
Okay, I'm dead
No, no
Looks at the ingredient list. There's so many
There's so many girl. There's so many. We're so like there's a skill thing
I can upgrade it
We can upgrade our skills
We have skills
We we've been suffering and for what?
What are you what are you putting into your skill tree? I'm just doing one of everything
Wait, how many clicks do you have 13? Oh my god
This whole time
I'm so I'm so in a mood
I don't know what kind of mood it is, but I'm in that fucking mood
This whole time
Thank you for the 10 gifted finish
Wait, I wasn't looking can you do it again?
Look at you
What a tricky bunny
Oh
If you feel bad
But like it'd be cool, you know, it's like doing a flip
No, I'll drop the cheese
I can't believe there's a skill tree. I can't believe there's a fucking skill tree
I didn't realize there are the skill tree until low now. Thank you boy for the five gifted
I still think it's hilarious. I was like everyone behave around serenity
I
And then I and then I was like, all right, it's my bestie
Yes, I can consume more
I got to keep the taco yaki. I put into my dip the batter. I mean batter is now dip
Just a little extra. We love our summon now out here
Oh shit, I didn't listen to my own fucking rules. I said I'm so sorry
I I get so distracted. I like flipping the balls. It's really fun
It's like I love flipping balls
Let's flip them
Okay, I'm gonna see if I can do my little trick of getting that spare. Nope. Can I get the spare ball?
I think I can
I'll put in the the stuff for us
I'm lasting longer. I'm lasting way longer now that we put the skill in
You're doing way better
Oh, shit. Well, we gotta make it to at least four day four
We gotta we gotta make it today like 100
I like that you can just hear me slamming my face
I
Business now, you know, like straight straight taco yaki business taco yaki party taco yaki
They weren't kidding about the survival part. They really weren't taco yaki. Thank you. You sat all by the way
Do
Fun mashing
This is so chaotic
It was a terrible idea to try
to try to
feel like in corporate like real life squats
Gave up in half an hour
I'm down. I if we wanted to try it again, I would I would
Mama ain't no quitter or mama didn't raise no quitter. She raised me a quitter
She needs to know our limits and to take breaks when needed
Any gym bro will tell you it's important to have a break or something. I don't know. I'm not a gym bro
I am so scared of the gym mostly because of the cost
Oh my god, I know it's so expensive now
Then they have like the cancellation fee and like the membership fee and then the
Then the then the like overhead fees and I'm like, what the heck fee
I know
I've I've been looking into getting my own gym equipment at home. But like gosh, that's expensive too
Oh
50 squats
I feel like it's lied to me. I feel like I did more than that in real life
I know
This game this game doesn't count the real life squats. They don't know they don't know you've been squatting
They don't know your powerful legs your glutes
My glutes are screaming for the high heavens
Good, you know, I feel like I wouldn't be dying this fast if I was low on protein in real life
Like I feel like what are we even?
What kind of
paper skin and glass bones motherfucker. Okay skill tree I
Come 14 skills. There you go
During malnutrition time can be accepted. Yes. Yes
Absorption what what do you mean absorption?
I dig the burnt one
Like that's what I did I just upgraded everything
Okay, because I think the absorption makes your like protein and stuff last longer
Got you
And I'm like bitch better last longer
Honestly
Like I am done being a weak baby
Terrible genes
Extra absorb or I guess not absorb in
I want to be extra absorbent. Let me absorb. Okay, so I have two so let me do these four
Yeah, oh, you're right. You're right. You're so right
Okay
And then it like lasts a bit longer
Thank you for the two dollar tip. Thank you, darling visa pie
Remember no matter how many takoyaki you eat and how sick it makes you never stops
Eaters are quitters
Okay, well, they're not wrong
Count as a roguelite. We do have the skill tree. You're right. It is kind of
I'm like, I mean sometimes are not wrong, but you don't have to say it out loud silly
It's the unspoken rule for a reason
Going out speaking all the unspoken things silly
Like this is why we can't have secrets
Is that true senpai you get excited to tell me everything about your life
That's pretty cute senpai
And you get so excited you're just like, oh boy, I can't wait for mercy to know how I feel about spinning
Okay, we're on the fourth day. Oh my god, we are
Oh, you are that's how I look now you survive my queen
Don't let them don't let them take your life away. Oh, I should eat
It's gonna be like a while before they take my life away
Yeah, no, you're living look at you
Oops, I actually ate it
We're like strong now because we're like there was a skill tree
We figured out how to play the game
Oh, yes, let me squat squat and eat squat and eat
It's like it's like those competitive, um eating
Uh, you know like the guys sweet hot dogs that report to july or whatever
Oh, yeah
Yeah, that's what it's called. Apparently they don't even like chew. They just swallow
No, no, it's kind of more fucked up than that really
Yeah, no, they dip it in water first and then they just kind of swallow it
Which like I feel like is worse, you know
Like like it's one thing if you're just gonna like gobble the glizzy like that
When you dip it in water first like, I don't know now it just feels worse, you know
Like it just it feels wrong
I think I'm a little on protein so I'll take some of these mats. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah
I will
Up there is a lot of protein
This four-corner. Thank you. Thank you darlin. Thank you darlin
Like
I always see those and I'm just like I
I don't think I can do that because then I don't know the competitive eating makes
Eating not fun. Oh my god. Yeah. No, you skip over the best part of eating which is enjoying your food
You know like it feels very much like I don't know then why eat, you know
I like putting things next to each other
Oh no, oh no, except when it doesn't match up like that. Uh, oh
No, not again, not the protein again
We'll flip the protein parts
No, it's okay. We got this we're we understand
We unlock the eggs
They probably give you like really good, you know
Like it probably gives you a lot more
I'm the number one egg hater
I
See now the music's like back to back to chillin now we're back to chillin
Let's scare you now now we get to enjoy our takoyaki having a good time
Oh my god, oh no now the music's changing
I think they have to cycle through the music
Yeah, that's fair. That's fair. I I guess I would go crazy if I was listening to the same song for like 15 hours
Yes, there it is
Did you ever hiss at people in school? I hissed at people right now
Oh disgusting this toothpick is gonna be gone. I'll eat this one. I'll eat this one
Don't worry. It's okay
Some guys who can't eat the eggs because then how will they smooch you, you know
Can't can't cross contaminate. You can't cross contaminate. Can't cross contaminate
It's okay because I'll brush my teeth and use mouthwash and then and then and floss
Ha ha ha floss. I'll I'll even do use the water floss
Oh god, yeah, I would use the water floss for you. I'll let my gums bleed
They're so violent. I'll use the floss. Yeah, oh shit the protein's down
No
Protein down don't let them get hurt my queen
This is such like a sonic song. Oh my god
Oh
And I have to I might have to eat an egg
I'm so sorry
It's it's a it's a vegan egg. It's a vegan egg. It's a vegan egg. Ha ha ha. That's a total egg
It's a total egg. It's meant to pretend to be an egg
Ugh
It does give you a lot more protein though damn
Damn you eggs damn you eggs and your your protein
You're not worth it
Okay
Okay, we have a system. I'm definitely not long for this world
But I'll be longer for this world. I'm gonna cook these these steaks for me
protein protein
Protein protein protein
Protein
Wow, I love you and your protein
Wow, your protein is very impressive
Hey, you have an impressive amount of protein today
I should have about to die without protein
No, it's the protein the protein. You know why we hate protein now
Get him out of here
Hey, I got it
Oh, by the way, Serenity is so good with voices
You're like, oh
Hello, you silly little senpai you funny money little hog champ
Sussie little bakas you alpha omega
You empreg enthusiasts
Hey
I just look over there going crazy. It's good your voice range is really good
Oh
Like this cutesy voice of hers is like her her like my my favorite voice because it's her
This is so much fun. Oh my god, we've got a french fry, but I'm dying
Yeah, I got french fries
You're on day five you're on day six
I'm on day six, baby
Nobody can stop you. Nobody can stop you
I'm about to fucking die though. So six is the end
No
They can't they can't do this to you don't need any of these these are all cucumber
These are all cucumbers cucumber hate
cucumber hate
You
Fuck the fucking the rhythm you have to get in for this game is crazy
I'm like, I'm so multifaceted right now. It's not the right way
It's not the right way at all
I'm really oh
Yeah, baby
This bitch this bitch has eggs
Oh my god, I have her last candy. I have her last candy. Yes
Oh my god, oh my god
We got eggs. You got so many eggs. What the hell? I know I'm just covered in them
Oh, do you want to take it? Do you want to take it? I took an egg. Don't worry about it
What be there?
All calorie free
Yeah
Which means we can eat as much as we want
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god
There's uh, there's a bar
Oh my god, I'm dropping everything. I'm
We're panicking or calorie panicking. I'm panicking. I'm panicking. I'm not ready
Oh, and they fry faster too
These are so fast. They're so bad. These balls are crazy. These balls are insane. Ah, I'm dropping balls left to run
I'm not ready. I'm not ready for this. I wasn't ready for the candy explosion
Who I oh god, I'm just oh my god. I'm miss clicking like crazy
Just fill it in
Fill it in fill her up keep on going keep on going and then pick and then you can just pick these up
As long as long as we eat
Just keep eating
I'm so locked in sorry senpai's I gotta I gotta
She's busy
Pre-occupied
Let me senpai's but uh
We gotta get calories
Senpai's why aren't you helping us senpai's you're supposed to be
Are you a vacuum cleaner? It's over. It's over
It's okay. I'm like so low on calories right now. So we can eat
Yeah, no, I gotta fill up my my caloric intake right now
I'm like dizzy Jesus. That was crazy. That was crazy. Thank you for the two super chat. He's at all. Thank you
And thank you darlin
visa pie
For and I thought my swallowing joke was sus. Thank you for your word serenity always good to know there's someone encouraging
mercy to they're just
In just our um
Oh
Thank you for you for the five super serenity is going on about ball
You know balls need to be kissed too. Have you ever kissed a golf ball? They need kisses try this fry by the way over here
Oh my god, we'll do oh my god. Thank you. I'll cook it right now. Oh my god
Is it good? I think so. I think it gives you more fat
Let me let me let me sauce her up
Oh, she gives more carbs. Never mind. It was carbs
No
It's inflating. Oh, I haven't been doing squats. Ah
You're saying I stopped doing squats. I was like, hmm, but then I looked over and I was like, oh, I'm kind of kind of low
All right, let's
egg
We have like oh
Okay, oh
There you go
And then I think eggs and the since our protein seems to be the one going down the most
Yeah, we are low protein girls. We do not eat protein bars. We do not go gym
We we don't drink those powders
We do not drink the powder
My bitch ass looks at way and it's like no way
Speaking of way protein is like one of those things that actually have eggs in them
Protein has eggs in it. Yeah, like for protein powder. Oh, I got I got pork now
I've been surviving
I don't I'm still at five days
You're getting like all the fancy meat. Oh, no tackle
No tackle for us no tackle for us
Maybe it is getting too easy for us. Maybe we do go start doing squats again
Oh
Hold on. I'm so sorry. I'm so sorry. I have to take an idol meeting right now
My my girls
Oh my god, are you girls ready for some girl chat?
Have a good idol meeting. I love you
Oh my god. Hey girly pops. All right, what's happening? What's the pops? What's the pops girlies?
How are we doing tonight? Are you guys having fun?
The squats did this the squats did do this
Blame. Oh, shit. I gotta start doing squats blame them
Finally
God, where is this tree?
It's always been girl talk you silly billies you silly billies
I'm just watching a bunny and a scissor talking. What about you? I'm talking to these scissors and they're pretty cool
I'm so happy first off sometimes. Thank you for being so
kind and welcoming
For this oh my god, she's gonna die for this collab
It has been such a wonderful time already
And like I know you haven't even been like alive that long
But like it's been such a delightful time
So thank you for being such warm and welcoming sometimes for me because like
I love nancy so very very very very much
And I'm just so delighted and happy to
To be with her again. No, she's dying babe. You gotta eat. Babe wake up. Babe wake up. Babe. You can die
Babe babe you can't you can't you can't go out like this. You can't go out like this, babe. Please
Please
I need to play I need a moment of silence as we play and grieve for my beloved as I as I grieve
Is the eye
Oh
I miss her every day every day I look out my window and I think god damn
Where's my love mercy?
Asked in the super chats. Can we get can we get some apps in the super chats?
All I want to do is hear my love my love of my life mercy moody
voice one more time
And and we're so lucky to hear it with every donation every senpai
Just it reminds me so much of her it fills that void in my heart
That's been around ever since she she was taken too early from us ever since ever since that rap bastard
Of takoyaki ever since they stole our kohai
Why are you made to do?
Thank you senpai. Thank you in this small in this time
In in this time of grief for all of us, you know
What what more can we do other than to say?
To say f and thank god I miss my kohai my sweet sweet mercy the girl who would laugh and make me smile
Well, I don't I don't know what you guys are talking about that hasn't existed in years
But you know, you know what couldn't fix it
Seeing the
She's gonna be so confused
But you know what you know what she's all gonna be confused because we're grieving we're grieving right now snippets
We're all grieving
you me
The curtains the floorboards
All grieving for our beautiful mercy
Where where is she?
I miss mercy
She died doing what she loved I'll miss her maniacal laughter fireworks never I live it scared me for a moment
Oh
What are we gonna do?
It's like
It's like I don't even know how to go on without her bros. I don't even know what am I gonna do
Who am I gonna text every morning and every evening?
Who am I gonna wish who am I gonna say I love you to?
What am I gonna do with my life now?
Without mercy, there's nothing
There's no point to anything
She is the point. She's our scissors
She is the point. She is the inciting action. She is everything. We are just ken
She is everything. What are we? Oh, shit. I'm gonna die. What am I without her?
Might as well be dead
Might as well be dead if I can't be with the beautiful wonderful queen mercy if I can't be with her
Maybe maybe maybe it is best to go on to that sweet good night
Okay, she's back
I'm dying. Oh no. Oh no
I lost my nails
Oh
You know like my press on nails I did earlier today. Yeah. Yeah, they're so cute. How did you lose them?
I lost two nails
Oh
I don't know where they went. I remember walking upstairs. Okay senpai
I was walking upstairs and then I remember I'm not wearing a shirt
And then I heard footsteps and I was like, no, we can't let mama or papa see me like this
I ran down
wore my shirt
They can't know they can't know
And then like I was just like, oh, I'm so tired because I think papa
Papa
Took the bottom the downstairs
Bathroom I had to go up the stairs like two sets of stairs and I was like
I think I'm gonna die because I did so many squats
I went to the idle meeting and then I looked at my hand. I was like
Two of them are gone
Wait, did the other ones go?
Oh my god
So then I was like spent a little bit going where'd they go? Where'd they fucking go?
Well, I was more concerned. I thought you lost them in like well at the idle meeting and I was like, how
How did you lose? How did you lose them at the idle meeting? I don't know
Anyways, I'm gonna peel these nails off because clearly they have a very not great glue
So they were so cute. They were so cute and then and then I was like, what the hell they just don't last
It happens, but they were so cute
like
Oh
I can't believe it died while I was paused this game doesn't pause
This game does not pause. They do not stop for anybody
Don't take these oh god, oh god
Welcome to my hell welcome to my dark and twisted mind
Ah
Okay, I will upgrade these two
We try back in a baby back at it again a crispy fucking cream
Oh
Yeah, don't worry me in the sun pies. We were completely normal. We didn't do anything crazy or weird
We were very normal. What were you doing?
Nothing. What were you doing?
Uh-huh. Uh-huh. What were you doing? Uh-huh. Yeah, you say that when you lie
Try to be normal a day in her fucking life
No, no, no all of chat knows what I say when I'm lying
Oh
It's like you can't hide things for me
No, we were just we were grieving that you died in game, you know, but we were normal about it
She's so mischievous. She's so mischievous
It's like I don't trust her but I do
I just love being a little shit. What can I say?
There's nothing more satisfying in life than being a brat, you know, it's true
I want to be a brat a lot of the times
It's really fun. Like
It's so it's so fun being disobedient. Like it's so fun
Being a little shit like do you ever you know that meme where it's like do you ever want to just go like ape shit?
You ever just want to be like you want to
That's old
It's not that old it's like old internet terms sure, but like it's not that
Like oh shit, what's the term I recently I was taught this term recently
It's it's it's not it's not christmas cake levels
Christmas cake
You mean like what they call hags?
Yeah, I don't like the term christmas cake because I feel like it's so rude
It is it is it's very loud, but it also implies that you're not fucking looking forward to that christmas cake all fucking year
Are you kidding me? I'm
I'm looking forward to that christmas cake now. Are you kidding?
Also christmas cake sounds great. What the heck?
I want a christmas cake right now, so I but
I've been laying the term recently. It's fun being like yeah, I know a new word
But yeah, I don't like the term hagg or christmas cake because I just feel like we're using hagg wrong
We're using hagg runs. We aren't witches here
We're not that's what gets me if you're gonna call me a hag I have to be living in the fucking woods
Like I am in the gingerbread house
Yes, I have to be a fucking like bog witch. I have to be a fucking
You know
You guys want milk you guys want milk like come on
Be so for real right now
No
But you are ready for hag levels yet
You don't know what a real hag is until
Tell you how the old crone in the woods
It's like yeah, I like haggs and then it just shows like the fucking like d&d hag monster
Oh
I would though would you not I would that kind of hag would every have this ham thing can I have that? Yeah, have the ham
Please
Eat up eat your fill. Thank you
Oh god, I have not been paying attention. I
I I started just being like you're having a good time
And now you're like panic now. I'm just like oh, it's business
So happy I get to say our names together girl. I know that's like a weird thing to be happy about but like
I'm so happy. I I really miss this. I'm so happy right now
It was a little rough. I'm not gonna lie a little rough below for a little bit being like man
I gotta we gotta wait, you know
Oh my god, it sucked it sucked. It sucked. It's just
I've been but like it was I do think
shit
Anyway, like it was it was like every second of waiting though, you know every moment of waiting for you
I just
I would wait one million years
I'm being pissed
Even if it meant I got just the chance to talk with you again, I would wait any amount of time
So sweet
Oh god, oh god, I'm gonna die. Don't die. I miss too hard
I
Miss too hard now now my tummy's like a girl you spend all your
Your skill points on raising you have no protein. You have no protein
That's gonna be like the new insult you're gonna go up to somebody and they're gonna be like, yeah, how are you today?
I'm like, yeah, I'm fine. But you know like I'm protein maxing
Protein maxing tackle. Yeah
Yeah, sorry, I can't come out to the hangout today, bro. I'm protein maxing my taco yaki game right now
You want to get it you want to understand
But let me let me let me eat beef beef or chicken
Oh, you got chicken
No, no, sorry. I was quoting popteen epic
Beef or chicken. What did you say?
Yes
Sometimes the vocal stims happen
I'm taco pilled in protein maxing
I think we're gonna make it guys I've squatted 100 times
My thighs are insane. Shit my paprika
I like my little flowers. They look like a little flowers. It's just really cute. It's so cute. Just like you
Yeah, do you know you?
Cutest scissors in the world
Scissors I barely even know her
Oh
Oh, yeah
Like your bunny ears and my scissors match and then you're like big hair
Your hair
hair speakers
My hair vents so I can breathe
Wait, no, I kind of like hair speakers better because I'm so fucking loud
Girl you just added to the lore
That's how I'm so loud. Oh shit. I'm fucking dying again. No, no, no
Don't let them take you away from me. Not again. Not again. I was only two days alive man. No
My fat
My fat reserves. I'm just burning calories
Not enough calories. I got so much dang cars, but not enough protein
Just like I'm just eat the ham
Yeah, I'm doing I'm doing the keto diet takoyaki where I just eat the fillings
Yeah
I'm gonna fucking die
No, no, no
God it's bad because like I
I have to idle meeting and I'm like, um
It's okay. I'll entertain in your place
But like no the problem is I'm a try hard girl
That's the problem. The problem is I don't want to die. I'm like I can hold it
No
Don't hold it let it out
Let me let me let me let me just set up. Let me just let me just let me just set it up, you know
I mean, let me let me set up some
Some meats and stuff for me to come back to so I won't die terribly
No
My protein's so bad same. Oh my god, we're in like the same fucking boat right now
Senpai
Okay, okay, I'm gonna I'm gonna be okay. I love you
Oh
Isn't she the sweetest sorry, I'm gonna fucking die probably
Let's see serenity has chosen
Thank you sato for the five dollar super chat that I didn't get to see saying I don't think I can take this if I got a joy
Everyone has everyone has to like
potty
I mean, I mean I don't mean
I need to upgrade I need to upgrade some of these
Here to upgrade the nutrition
An endurance
Yeah, we're good. Azura welcome to the stream
Everyone's on an idle meeting break except for me
Which by the way, I'm about to fucking die
I died no way I died before well
I have hiccups
How is the stream? Oh my god, I'm not dead yet
Welcome serenity. We just got raided by Azura
Hello, hello, hello everyone. I'm
If you didn't know this is serenity my my best day introduce yourself
So I got locked in I got so locked in
Serenity is my best friend who
We are having a mayhem time right now trying to eat all these dang takoyaki's and trying not to die
We're just doing our best. We are we're struggling. We're fighting for our lives right now
Then you have to do squats. We were doing squats earlier
Like real squats and then died
Low energy
Well, I can die you can can you die from low energy? I think so eat you can't you don't die from low energy
Seriously, I was at zero energy
You know what this means we can abuse the calories we can abuse our caloric intake
Okay
Oh
Sure
Only nice things to say about everyone's favorite mother, you know
she reads in
but um
You know my fairbie mask, right?
No, you didn't did you wear it with the the egg man?
I was having one of those nights. Yeah
No
This is like
Weird black look too
Oh my god, too. Holy shit
But yeah
I know exactly what you did
I was just being in a little freak, you know
It's girly things
Squat
Okay, okay, okay, let's grab all these
Yeah, some ham in there
Like the meat texture is really nice like it's all rendered so good
Girl, we are living. We're about to get oh fuck
We've got so many peppermints
We're about to fucking which by the way, I think would taste probably freaking awful. Oh discussing
Bless you
I get excited around you too. Oh, that's so cute though. Always love serenity my bestie
Hey, I love you. Hey, I'm so happy to see you anytime I get the notification that you're right
Okay, if I'm I'm like just looking I'm like
I love you too
Thank you for the five it wasn't egg man, but she did have the
It's gonna send her arm strong. Thank you. I see
Is this is I want to say this but you haven't changed like
Yeah
Yeah, I'm still the same cringe bitch
You you haven't either you're still the most hardworking delightful girl that I've fallen in love with
And that sometimes are so lucky to have
Stop it. You make me blush
Oh
Look at all these cucumbers
I know what did they even do? I haven't actually experimented what they do
I don't they don't give protein. That's for sure
They for sure don't give us any of the protein. I'll take all the cucumbers and and do an experiment
I feel like they make it so it's easier to eat so you can eat multiple of them
I think it's it's go carbs look like it's going up
Maybe oh our carbs what stops me from overeating
The vegan taco yaki the best vegan taco yaki in town gosh, I really want to try taco yaki like
real vegan taco yaki
It can't be hard to make I feel like the only hard part is the ball is the grill, right?
Well, no because the sauce is the type of um mayonnaise if I
Well vegan mayonnaise is really easy to get it's the same price as regular mayonnaise. So that's easy
Then yeah, it shouldn't be too hard because the the batter itself is just the type of pancake batter
Oh, she's my fat
Oh, no
I need that cheese
Oh my god
Somebody get her the cheese
On heat up. Thanks. Oh cheese up here
Take your cheese as well
Yes, take take take take
I feel like pork would also give good fat
I'm like when did all my protein die?
I know
Wait overeating. What do you mean overeating? I'm starving
I did not have my piggy fill. Thank you
I really have to stop calling it that
Like I hope you I hope everyone knows this isn't a bit. This is just how I talk
Two candies which means we can eat our fill and not die
I'm piggy fill finally
No, let me eat the final peppermint
Oh my god, oh my lord
Okay, let's let's prep let's prep for it. We're gonna prep for it
crazy
Okay, are we ready? Yeah. All right, let's go. Let's go
Fever
Okay, no not as freaked out this time. We're put together. We know what we're doing
Once you finish eating the start battering
Yeah, yeah, yeah hit with the sauce
Eat everything up better better better. Fuck that one guy that we forgot lonely sausage. You're fine
I
Get everybody in there. Don't care about what we get. We just put it all in
Fuck out in the cheese
Give me my fucking calories. I'm about to fucking die
Oh god, oh god, okay sauce it up because that's important
Okay, okay batter time batter up. Hell. Yeah
batter night. I don't know. Anyway, we have to eat more
God, why am I just getting cute four five six cucumbers?
Root ass dishes all of these. I'll eat all the cucumbers. It's fine. I love cucumber
It's my favorite dessert. Why is it with fat that I always die with the fat?
Oh god, oh god, that was nothing
Oh, did you see that though? We were so in sync mind meld
Hey
That was like beautiful
Okay, huh
Please please give us oh damn it dang it. Okay, it's it's fine. It's okay. You know, we didn't even want all of that
It's that's not even that good for a fever, you know
I'll start I'll start
loading us up with more more balls
It's like literally are we like trapped in a chair or something?
Yeah, yeah, this is like I've never seen the movie saw
This is our sawchap. This is our saw health for ever eating
He's like would you like to play a game? It's like yeah, we love games
Oh god, could you okay? Hold on. I need a saw movie where they put like
Influences, but I need like, you know the brain rot influencers
I need the ones who are like by my cryptocurrency by my cryptocurrency. Wow
Are you single?
Oh
It's like about to like get get sawed and it goes like wood
What would jake saw do
If you flirted with him, what how would he even respond? I don't know. I think I've tell us to shut up or be like, okay
You know what?
Just just rip off their mouths
They're they're they're tricky as gone
So what if I could fix him? What if I can fix it? I don't think you can fix anyone
Mom that sounded so mean
I
You can't fix
Just me in the background girl, I don't think you can fix yourself
Oh
When you're too broken and you can't even be fixed
Oh my god
That too
For the first time ever the fat problem is happening
Why are
Why are we fat?
No, we're lacking the fat. Why are we?
It's like we're out like one of those reality tv shows and they're like, oh my god. You're so skinny and we're over here
Eating like our body weight in balls and we're like, I know
I don't want to be
Oh
I don't know I'm dying. I've got 30 seconds to live
We're just shoveling food in our mouths and we're just like, I don't know. I don't know why we're so thin. Help. Help. Help. I'm dying
I just keep doing squats and eating
I said
Thank you. He's hot. Oh die you
certified
All consumers I'm out
You're right
You say you say certified and I have just Kendrick Lamar brain rot. So I was about to sing not like us
It's like it's like a fucking calling car now
I love my brain rot bunny girl
I'm the worst kind of brand. Oh shit. I have no protein. I don't even remember why I put in these balls
Take some of these balls
Take my balls. I take the balls. I take out the balls and I put the balls in my mouth
I don't remember this in the Mario movie
We should
I have a day off tomorrow so I can rest my voice from like I knew this would happen
You know, I like knew it would happen
I should have done that. I should have been smart like you. I'm not I am I am but a fool. I am but the fool
My protein badge
Oh my god, I'm about to die again. No
Don't don't do this. Don't let them take you
Don't let them take you away
I need that's a fast death. That was a super fast death. Hold on
Gotta get my metabolism up
Or my squats up
I gotta do my squats up. Yeah
Yeah, squats are pretty good. They take out like a lot of calories
Squats up so that we can take the calories because I keep on getting full too fast
And not enough time
Too full not enough squatting happening like
Like for some reason we're like, oh, I gotta rest my tummy is so full and it's like, um
We are literally dying otherwise
I didn't say you could get a break silly
Eat more
This is this is like actually torture like what is the goal? Why are we dying? Why do we have to do squats?
We gotta do squats so we can eat more. Uh, here. I'll give us like a map hat like over analysis of this thing
Clearly we're being held against our will and some
fucked up
takoyaki eating
restaurant and
We're criminals. So this is our punishment. We're but monsters and cogs to
To the regime, you know, but that's just a theory a game theory. Thanks for watching. Thanks for watching
Don't forget to like and subscribe if you like the channel
I don't actually know. I never watch map hat in my life. No, you got it right. That's what he said
I'm not you pass you and I'm about to die. He says all of these verbatim word for word
Oh
It's like why are we tackling? Why are we yaki?
We tackle to yaki we yaki to tackle
Half of these aren't over half of these aren't even tackle yakis
I can't turn these what's what the what's what this?
What oh sometimes it glitches out for me to want to dance and let me
It's just being kind of kind of being rude being rude. Let me eat
It's like no just star just star
It's like this this is it
This is the final frontier
Actually burning more calories is pretty good
Yeah, do we do we keep our levels? Yes, we do
We do
My goodness, I'm so coffee
What's cause I had I had a milkshake earlier. That was a terrible idea. By the way, I get really flummy
Same
Apparently I was my journey. Whoa. She taught me this apparently, but oh apparently um
That's just what dairy does to you. So like if you're ever doing like a karaoke or something
You should never have dairy before
I was like, oh my gosh, I feel like I'm dying
Which sucks because I am a girl who loves her sweet little treats and um
Oh god, should I just fuck the sauce?
But yeah, I love sweet little treats and it's like a reward, you know, oh god
I mean it's like a reward
It's cuz like I was like, oh, yeah, oh, yeah, I can have myself a little treat today
I was like, I have like my nails done and everything
Whoo
I'm gonna get myself like a little treat because I'm hanging out with my bestie
And little did I know that I would be dying with my bestie
What flavor milkshake was it? Uh, orange cream's a call
Oh
What's your what's your go-to ice cream like a
um
ice cream truck order
If they have like cotton candy or some like weird flavor, so I usually get the weird flavor
Like butterscotch or or or like flowers
Butterscotch is so good
I guess usually my
My go-to
But like it's usually like like cotton candy, which is just like a very sugary taste
Cotton candy is good
It's interesting because I know I know like we have different ice creams
But like oh shit, why did I do that? Why did I do that? I shouldn't have done that
Why did I why did I flip them all just grab them don't worry
I was zoning out. I was so I just wanted to flip the ball
She's like we just wanted to flip
Oh god, I'm not squatting. I'm just flipping balls left and right. I'm not my head is not in the game
Her ass is not gaming
Don't worry. We can finish these balls. Look at that. We got him. We did it
It's just zoned out, you know, this is like Korean barbecue all over again
I'll go in because I like being the one who cooks and then I'll just
Put on too much meat and then nobody can finish it
Everyone's like too full and then we gotta sneak into the bathroom
Okay, what was the craziest thing you've ever done for an all you can eat?
Like okay to to escape the charge. Yeah
Okay, okay, so um, I
I took so I have this cute bag with me, right?
So I I told like a bunch of
Oh, I shouldn't say it like this. Um, I gotta say it in that a suspicious way
Uh-huh, uh-huh
I
Placed all of the food in my mouth
And then I went to the butt because there was a lot so I put food in my mouth
But I also
Put some in my purse and napkins and then I ran to the bathroom
For seeing the T. You know
Because I couldn't we couldn't take the food with us. Yeah, we weren't allowed
So, yeah, that's this that's I think the craziest was was that to to properly dispose
of the food
of the Korean barbecue
I think the craziest thing I ever did was like throwing up
Throw it up and went back for more
That's real shit though. That's real shit. You're just puking rallying. That's different. That's a party girl thing
And the the other friends were like
We're like, okay
I'm gonna go
shit it out
And then we'll make some room
No, it's just things too long
They were like my stomach hurts. We're going now
No
I didn't even I don't even think that's crazy. I think that's pretty crazy. I don't know
I don't know if this says anything about me
I don't know if I'm just outing myself right now, but like, I don't know. That's not like crazy crazy. That's pretty like that's real, you know
Oh
All you can eat is good when the charge is $30 plus per person. I'm I am like
No, I can rally any day of the week
I mean like
It's it's the woo girl, you know motto
It's every girl that you meet drunk in the bathroom. We we're just we're just like that
We're gonna puke rally cheer each other on for it. Hold back each other's hair. Like that's what we do, baby
Oh my gosh, it's rola
We're suffering this game is hard
For hamster said it was like a calm game. That was a lie
Well, professor hamster never said it was a calm game. Wait, what?
Professor hamster just said I think you would like this game
When they're not wrong professor hamster is not wrong. I very much like this game
Tackle yucky torture sim is real
Welcome to the tackle yucky torture sim. We eat squat and eat again
Yeah, earlier we were squatting real
Real not fake
We're squatting with with our tackle yucky eaters. We stopped. We could not we could not continue after half an hour
We were like if we can't do this anymore. Okay, but half an hour of doing that straight is pretty fucking crazy
We we we we we rule
Oh
I'm stealing yours
Instantly takes them all
We such picky eating
We actually can't die in this game. Yes, we die frequently
Look at my protein
In fact, why are we why are we losing them?
I don't know
We're not even we're just sitting we're not even doing anything we exist and we lose protein and fat
We are not gym bros. We are not we are not boys who go to the gym
Okay, okay, okay, let me bloop bloop bloop bloop bloop you
Put you in protein
protein
I can't believe we can get crab arms
No, no, no, I can't be full. I have six fat. I can't be full
No, it's fine. I couldn't imagine playing this with more people
Wow, I think it would be chaotic. It would be so it'd be so insane
And guess what I think we're gonna do it
Yeah, I feel like we can do it
I'm gonna see I believe in us. I think we could do anything ever. I don't have enough skills
No, no, no, no, no, no, no
I don't like this
How many get how many people does this game support? I think four four. Yeah four at a time
Yeah, see so one person can sit here and one person can sit at the end over there
It's like table tops and rolls except
Not at all like that game. Yeah, each person will like have pretty much the same appearance since we're in uh
Hmm
Yeah, we each get our little seat our little our little solo play but like
But where's the fun in that?
Oh my gosh, I'm about to fucking die again
Like yeah, you can be lonely. Oh, why would you be lonely when you can come back? It's a party. Yeah
You want a party alone?
Why party alone when you can party with some cute girl?
I think like you would go alone to just unlock the
The extra stuff
That would be smart. That would be like the smart thing to do
But guess what? I'm not smart at all
I'm I'm a dumb girl. I'm dumb girl. I'm dumb girl who has fun
Girls who girl girl and girls who don't go wait, you know
Wait, no stop stop why am I malnutritioned? I'm I'm not malnutrition. I'm dumb as fuck boy
I
Start spinning
This is the peppermint. Yeah, that one's the peppermint you can have it. Thank you
You can have your peppy mint
Can I have a peppermint?
You can have a peppermint
This is gonna suck. Come on, squat faster
Okay, two beef. Beef gives a little bit of fat. What gives us more fat? What are like fatty fluids?
I feel like pork could be fatty. I think cheese is fat. That would make sense
And
Protein is it has to be the meat the meats, right? Oh steak a thousand percent gives protein
Okay, it's like it's no longer takoyaki
Now we're like like going into like the caloric and take we can have you know, we're like really we're mapping it out
It's like I have to I have to have this much to survive
I need okay if I want to eat this many balls
I have to do this much these many squats
And this many full types and then I can have over 200 takoyaki in under three hours
Fuck
I'm gonna bomb. I'm gonna go. I'll take I'll take the bird ones
And I'll flip over some for you
Okay, all of these will be for you. Oh, thank you. Yes
Look how look at my fat and protein
terrible
I'm there with you. Oh, but you're on day like five you're living
Well, what's the max that we live to eight?
I think you bought to eight. I got to like six maybe
fuck
There we go
About the second my heart starts beating and I know the grim reapers at my door
knocking waiting for me to slip up and not eat a delicious piece of takoyaki
Look it's real fun
It's it's not looking good. It's not looking good
It's not looking good 10 seconds to squat and I can't do it five three two one
It's over
I can't believe he took you away
The grim reaper took me
What the fuck
How like how very not girls girl of the grim reaper to do that to you
It was too late
It was over
It was all ogre
It's all ogre now, baby
See see five five so so fun
Shrek ain't your average ogre son. I got a donkey who's wonky and I live in a swamp
Let me hear you stop say shrek
It's like well, let's see what we can see
Have you ever heard the shrek rap?
No
I think I've been seeing like that level of derange
I'm just promoting the show. I'm dead. I'm fucking done. I'm done so bro
I'm out if I sell
Wait, I might not be my candy
No
Oh my god, oh my god, I'm not out if I sell I'm not out if I sell we're back we're living
Okay, if you die we're flipping this and then we're starting life all over again
Wait, oh, but we have just one more candy. Yeah, this is it
Huh
Wait, I think I can live I think I can live eat the candy
I'll get the candy for both of us. Yes
I might die for it, but you know, let's chill
Yeah
Okay, but I do need to eat like no grab it grab it
Flip flip flip flip flip flip flip flip flip eat eat eat eat eat eat eat eat eat
Poor poor poor poor
Grab balls and go grab fall fall fall is life
fall is life
fall is life fall
eat, eat eat, eat eat eat eat
fall fall fall fall falling falling fell falling falling fall falling fall falling
retract
flip flip them as I I've I've put them in
whoa that's smart, that's smart, that's smart
you're so smart your brain is so beefy
and wrinkly and gorgeous
it has so much wrinkles just for you
They're so deep and wrinkled!
You brain is so rigid, it's like a vast canyon to explore!
Okay, oh god, oh god, I'm just grabbing, I'm just grabbing shit!
I'm not even, I'm lost in the sauce, baby, I'm lost in the sauce!
Nah, I'm so locked in, I'm so locked and loaded.
We're gonna have the best tokiyaki this side of the Mississippi.
How's our split in them?
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
Draw a madden.
Yeah.
Yeah?
A few calories.
Okay, okay, okay.
Suck it up.
Oh my god.
Okay, fever?
Fever helps.
Thank you, fever.
I was on the brink of this stuff, and now I'm alive, well and happy.
Oh dang it.
Nah, it's fine.
We got, we're back to like almost full.
That's great!
I know!
We can live to see another day!
We can be alive!
And squat more!
Yay, yay squatting!
At least we're not doing it in real life.
Yeah, you know that idea?
Cause I thought it was gonna be like a comma game.
Yeah, that was a terrible idea in hindsight.
Cause I thought it would be a comma game and screaming.
Literally like, yeah, I thought it was like, yeah, we'll probably like have,
probably have some time where we have to like just squat, squat like everyone's in a while.
It's like every single second of our life.
Like I didn't know it was gonna be this, this crazy.
Cause in the moment you were like, yeah, we have to squat in the game so we can squat for real.
I was like, huh?
Will you squat?
Day seven, we've been here for a week.
You've been here for a week.
I've been here for a day.
I've been here for a week.
I haven't, I haven't left, I haven't left this spot in a single week.
I'm, I'm getting, I'm getting a crazy sweat stain in this chair, my god.
I'm getting swamp ass.
Out of my swamp.
This is my swamp.
Get out of my swamp ass.
I need, I need that as booty choice.
I need that like, you know the juicy booty choice.
How long do you need to get out of my swamp ass?
Holy shit.
Oh my god.
I'll tell you a secret like after, after straight.
Oh, I'm so excited.
I'm so, I'm so excited.
It's gonna be my secret with you.
Haha, haha chat, haha sometimes.
You guys don't get to know.
You guys don't get to know the messy secret.
I do.
This is a secret for the girls.
Sometimes I hope you guys are having such a fun night too.
Like this is such a fun night.
Senpai.
Selfish but.
How much to buy Serenity's chair?
Hey.
Haha.
I don't know, we got, let's not how, let's not how, what is it?
Auctions work, you know?
It's like bet on it.
Get on it, bet on it.
Girl, have you watched High School Musical?
Yes.
Are you kidding me?
Bet on it, bet on it, bet on it, bet on it.
I love that like video.
Why are you keep running around like that?
Why are you moving like that?
How much to become Mercy's chair?
Senpais are spoiled.
You're so spoiled.
They are.
It's a little Senpai.
Well, I have to eat.
Mew, mew, mew.
Bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam.
Yes.
Bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam.
I couldn't, I could potentially tell the secret.
Yeah, but like do Senpais get to know?
You know, like doing?
They could get to know, but like at the same time just like, hmm, have you been good?
Have they been good enough to know?
Do they get to know the fun little, the fun Mercy secret?
I'll, I'll, I'll mess, I'll message you on Discord right now what it was.
And then you can, you can decide if they deserve to know.
Ooh, I get to decide.
Yeah.
I mean, Senpais happen pretty good.
When you were at idle meeting, they were pretty good.
Senpai!
Ugh, you know me.
I'm fucking weak when it comes to chats.
Ooh.
Ahh!
So, I mean like, okay.
Real?
Oh, they don't know.
They don't know that.
Oh, wait, they don't know.
Or do they?
It didn't send.
I, I hit shift and entered at the same time.
I mean, I think, I, oh, this is hard.
This is hard.
Cause like, I, I probably would pay while this information and only tell in like a members only stream.
Okay, I'll tell them in a members only stream.
Yeah.
Cause if they want to know like the good secrets, they gotta, they gotta earn their way to the good secrets, you know?
We will remind you.
You will have to remind me.
I also think you should add in the little added question that I asked.
I think you should let them know that story too.
This is a magical girl.
Are you kidding me?
That shit was cute.
What?
Actual cute girl shit.
Cutest girl in the whole world.
And sometimes they're going crazy.
They're like, what secrets, what secrets do you know?
Meanwhile, I'm like, yeah, I'll keep my secrets.
What secrets?
Are you really going to ask the mischievous bunny what you would like to hear the truth?
No!
I like seeing you guys squirm.
She's more of a sadist than I am.
I like being bully.
I like being evil.
Did we just say eat at the same time?
This is like besties.
It really is.
This is not even over.
We're like best friends.
The fact that we fucking eat at the same time.
It stinks.
Yeah, do you and your bestie eat at the same time?
I didn't think so.
Put some ham in here.
This one's so good.
Oh god, I'm dying, I'm dying, I'm dying.
I'm out of your protein.
I ate octopus.
Okay, we're good, we're good.
Here's some eggs.
Oh, thank you.
It's because I can't eat fast enough.
You're on day eight.
Oh my god.
He survived.
I have so many cucumbers.
It's cool, it's cool and unusual punishment.
Senpai, do you have a bestie?
Oh, oh, Senpai, I hope so.
Too.
Oh, that would be really cute.
Can I drop the cucumbers off the table?
Yeah, that's what I thought.
Technically.
Throw them on the floor.
I died.
That's okay.
Day eight is, is...
Back in the game.
I like that death doesn't really matter.
Death doesn't matter.
We get resurrected to eat more.
They just bring, it's like Groundhog's Day.
We wake up, we wake up in a different chair each time,
lost and confused, sweating, but hungry somehow, always hungry.
Always hungry, always eating, always takoyaki-ing.
Always takoyaki.
Never fully satisfied, just always takoyaki.
He's like, I got friends online that I'm a bit closer to.
We're not, we're not, we don't live in the same area, Senpai.
Like Serenity and I, Destiny decided that we must stay apart.
Yeah.
But like one day, maybe one day, maybe the other.
I hope so.
Same.
Like when, when like money allows it and then I can get like, you know...
Oh my god, I am not cooking you so much food when I meet you.
I'm vegan, I'm vegan!
I'm vegan!
No way!
I won't die!
You won't die!
It's so hard because there's so many vegan places near me,
and I'm just like, oh, I'll be so good for you!
There's a vegan bakery I'm next to!
Oh, seriously?
I love bakeries.
They smell good, but then most bakeries are like, you know, death.
Nah, this one's vegan.
I keep on eating the paprika!
I don't know what paprika does.
I think it's like cucumber where it's nothing.
Stop trying to make me eat my veggie tater.
I can't hear veggies like this.
It's fucked up, I don't want to eat vegetables!
They're saying, don't let me cook.
I'm not a bad chef.
What? No, you're cooking is good.
Sometimes.
You don't want to eat Mercy's cooking every day of the week?
Yeah, why don't you want to eat, you know...
Yeah.
Have my cooking all the time.
You don't think you're lucky enough to enjoy Mercy's cooking every day?
What's wrong with you?
Is it because of the takoyaki?
Are you just tired of eating takoyaki every day?
Is that the hint that you're trying to give?
Are you trying to say you're tired of eating takoyaki mean for three months straight?
I would make a mean...
I would make a mean sandwich.
Ooh, so flimmy!
I'm sorry.
No, it's okay, I'm just so excited.
I have no excuse for why I've been coughing so much.
I'm just like...
Milkshake was a terrible idea.
And I should be punished for my ideas.
No! No, you're kidding!
Your ideas are great!
Fuck anybody who thinks otherwise, I'll kill them!
I'll kill them!
I'll watch the lights stay from their fucking eyes.
If anybody ever makes you think that your ideas aren't wonderful and amazing, I'll fucking watch.
I'll watch and enjoy every second that they cry and sob, waiting, trying to survive,
and I'm gonna force feed them every one of your fucking thoughts!
They can choke and savor every last bit of their fucking pathetic lives!
I love her.
Oh my god, I love you too!
Trust me. Trust me, Senpai, we're crazy.
Yeah.
We're so crazy.
I love being a crazy bitch with you.
It's the best.
Okay.
I'll rip anyone limb from limb from you.
That's what besties do.
That's what besties do!
We rip and tear, baby. We rip and tear.
I know, I like this song a lot.
Violence is always the answer.
It is!
I try not to do it, but it's usually always the answer.
Because you're a good girl, you know?
You're like, nah.
You're about that slow-
How did I-
I died!
I'm after you, Takoyaki Hellman.
Okay.
Which one should I do? Absorption.
Maybe absorption should be better, because god damn!
We gotta really absorb all the Takoyaki right now.
Pour, pour and place an extra for ya.
Thank you.
Gotta get my calories up.
Gotta get, gotta get that.
Gotta get that boom boom pow.
Interesting.
You can eat-
You can eat them without the sauce.
Well, no.
You can eat like cucumber and paprika when you're kind of full.
Oh, okay.
So like-
So maybe that's it?
They can be like filler?
Maybe.
Maybe if you need like to just-
I don't know.
I don't know why you would need to eat more.
Why do we need to eat more?
Why do we suffer?
Why do we suffer with no candy?
Literally not even a little bit of candy.
Not even a little.
Oh, there it is!
You spoke-
Oh my god.
You heard me.
She heard me!
You spoke and it happened.
She was like,
I heard you were talking shit.
So I'm making like grand entrance.
And I'm over here like,
I'm so sorry, Miss Candy.
I would like to formally apologize.
I was talking shit.
And now I will get hit.
Bop, bop, bop.
Senpai!
Whoa, fuck them up.
Thank you for the two super chat.
Why are we still here?
Just to suffer?
Yes.
Senpai, you know,
I'm gonna say it.
You haven't eaten a single takoyaki
this whole time!
It's okay.
We're the takoyaki they want.
Oh, that's right.
They just stayed in room for dessert.
I saw, cause Koa is not feeding us.
I'm so sorry.
Um, I think you meant,
you're not feeding her?
Um, like, I'm so sorry Senpai.
You should be feeding her?
Excuse me?
This is so fun.
It's like, I would,
I would totally let Senpai eat a takoyaki,
but if I didn't click on them,
they would instantly be eaten.
Oh yeah, no, they would fucking destroy.
Just let us out of the cage.
I can't trust you.
Well, if they left out of the cage,
then how do we know they would stay
to enjoy all this delicious takoyaki?
Listen.
Don't trust them.
The moment you leave, the door unlocked?
No, no, take their little slimy fingers
and, like, unlock it,
and then you're just there waiting outside
because you know they're gonna do it.
Oh my god, they're like dogs.
Oh my god.
If you leave the door open for just a second,
they're gonna bolt,
even though they have everything they need.
They have food, they have love.
Moment, the moment that door is open.
Woof, woof, woof, they're out of there.
Exactly.
I can't trust them.
That's why they gotta be on the leash all the time.
It's for their protection, honestly.
I mean...
But it's okay.
I instructed the...
All this on Piest.
If anyone is running, we get the hammers.
And everyone...
There's, like, what, 200 and something
bones them human body?
Everyone gets one bone to break.
That's so fun.
I feel like that's so generous, right?
And some of them are bigger, so, like, you get extra hits.
Oh my god, that's so fun, though.
Like, that's so pinatical, it is, like...
I was like, why is...
What a fun time.
That would encourage...
That would encourage running, for me, honestly.
I would convince people to run,
just because, like, then I get a free hit.
Does that seem to think about me?
I'm like, I mean...
I will pass my answer, actually.
I think...
I think that means...
I think something about me that I...
Um...
Like, there's no candies inside me.
Yeah, the candies are your flesh.
Your organs.
Yeah, wait, you're so silly.
You're so silly, you're so full of stuff.
And you don't need all of your organs.
Like, I've stated this so many times.
You don't need all of them.
You're being selfish, hoarding all of them.
You know?
You have two kidneys.
You don't need both.
See, how long can I say shit like this
before it's not a bit anymore?
Before it's not a bit anymore?
What do you mean it was a bit?
Oh no, I'm dying.
Seriously.
Like, okay, but you know,
you can only do so many Google searches
before you're like...
Before the FBI comes and goes,
Hello, Serenity?
We'd like to talk to you about your Google searches.
Before my internet provider's like,
We're a little concerned
about what you've been searching up.
Why did you want to know
the price of the human heart
and every human organ?
So it looks exciting, Serenity.
And you know, you can't just say research
because it's like they're like,
well, what kind of research?
And then they ask way too many questions.
I know exactly.
I had to take things off my throne
because I was like, hmm...
I think I'll put me on a hat.
I'll put me on a hat.
I remember.
Because I was like, yo,
she's about to do such cool crafts from this.
Like, I'm so...
Like, the bonesaw?
I was so ready.
I was so ready for your bonesaw, Ike.
But like,
that's too many eyes on me, you know?
Yeah.
What's worse?
The FBI or the homeowner's association?
The homeowner's association?
The HOA, definitely.
HOA is rough, man.
You can't even have like a flamingo
on your lawn without the HOA being like,
how about you move out?
I don't get it!
You own the home!
I know!
Why the fuck do they care
if I'm gonna have like,
like a space alien
drawing on my front lawn, you know?
Like, come on, bro.
Let me have weird art on my front lawn.
Let me be weird and quirky.
I don't know why there's such actual haters.
The homeowner's association is wild.
Like, some of them demand to have like, a key to your place.
Yeah!
I know!
Why?
Bro, you ain't paying my mortgage.
Fuckin' put a ring on it if you want a key, Jesus.
Senpai!
Oh, thank you,
holy west,
for the tan,
for the bonesaw fun!
Oh, wonderful.
Always wanted another bonesaw.
Now I can do half the work.
Like, all the work in half the time.
Oh my god.
You guys are just helping her be more efficient.
Thank you.
I think Senpai's don't realize how,
how important efficient this is to you, you know?
Oh, they're gone.
Those are gone.
I'll take them.
Oh, it's a little burnt takoyaki.
Extra flavoring.
I'll take you to heaven,
because I'm about to be there in 50 seconds.
Oh my god, please let me squat.
Please let me squat.
Oh, we're so far away from a fever.
We're so far away.
I'm so sorry, dear.
It's over.
No, no, it's not over until I drop dead.
Man, it's over.
It's so fine.
We're so back.
We're back with the ham.
Ham across the way.
Wait, there's a story.
My mom has back when she lived in a
homeowner's association many, many years ago.
A friend of hers left for work one day
and forgot to close her garage,
and that HOA decided to sell all her stuff.
I would kill.
Including an $800 bike.
Excuse me?
What the fuck?
That has to be illegal.
That has to be...
That has to be illegal, yeah.
Like, contract or not, right?
I don't...
I honestly don't really understand how HOAs are legal
in the first place, to be honest.
Because it feels very much like,
I don't know, just some guy being like,
I don't fucking like you.
I'm gonna make your life hard now.
Fuck you.
And it's like, what?
That's why if I'm ever...
I like saw some houses.
Because I'm like house hunting kind of.
Like potential house houses.
I'm like...
Half of them have like,
a home owner's association fee
and I'm like, a fee to go with those bastards?
No.
Ugh.
So, Mercy house arc?
I'm so excited for you.
I'm trying to, I'm trying.
As soon as like, things stabilize,
I'm gonna, I'm gonna try my own,
try to get my own place,
get a down payment,
pay the mortgage.
Cause it's cheaper than rent.
I believe, I hope.
That's so upsetting that mortgage is,
is cheaper than rent.
That's crazy.
Like, I, I calculate.
What am I doing?
I calculated it.
That like,
Ah, not the cucumber.
That with insurance,
like yearly insurance and mortgage,
it's cheaper than rent.
Jesus.
Still.
Oh, and property tax as well.
It's so cheaper than rent.
Jeez.
Fuck that.
Honestly, I'm like,
this is a messed up system.
The fact that it's cheaper to buy.
Oop oop oop oop oop.
Balls, balls, gimme your balls, gimme your balls.
It's like, cheaper to buy,
but like a,
what do you call it?
Cough, cough, cough.
The um,
what do you call it?
The initial cost,
it's really high.
It's really high,
but like afterwards,
it's, it's, it's.
It's like better.
It's better.
I mean, it makes sense too,
because with like rent,
you are,
you're really just paying your rent
for, for ever essentially.
So like it definitely like
shuts out.
And like,
huh,
could you imagine?
Oh, I freaking died.
Oh, how?
No!
Oh!
I don't even have enough
to like,
upgrade any of my skills.
No!
That's terrible.
You can run out?
Oh shit, oh shit.
I don't have anything to like,
ugh, I'm dying.
This game's evil.
I feel like I,
I'm, I'm like,
I'm starting to get
to that point where I'm like.
We can,
whenever you're ready.
I'm, I'm,
I'm good to chill.
Yeah!
Like I think I'm getting
a little too excited too,
so like I'm,
I'm getting like,
what do you call it?
No, I feel you.
I'm good whenever you want to.
Yeah.
Yeah, I'm just,
I'm just happy to be here.
Are you kidding me?
I love you.
I like,
looked forward to this
so long.
I know,
I'm just,
I'm so happy right now,
you know?
Like,
I'm just,
I'm happy to be here.
I'm happy to talk
and hang out.
Like,
this is just fun,
you know?
Yeah.
I'm just getting
really flummy.
I feel,
I feel.
And like,
you know,
we can,
we can always collab again,
one other.
I'm not going anywhere.
Honestly,
we were like talking about
Senpai,
Senpai and
Sweetie Bunch,
because I know some of you
are here.
We were talking about
how we were going to like,
kind of like,
first it'll be my channel
and then we'll go to,
go to Serenity's channel
and then we're going to
collab back on my channel.
We're going to just like
switch all the time.
We're going to ping-pong it.
We're going to ping-pong
like these balls.
Because like,
I don't know,
I feel like that's,
unless it's like a game
where we have to have
both,
both POVs,
doesn't that,
when it's like one of those,
I don't know,
I'm trying to think of like a game
that's like that,
that would be played.
Did someone say ping-pong?
Alright.
Did you know
that they play ping-pong?
Wait, what?
When I'm not looking,
they play ping-pong.
What?
Feeling?
Look, look at Chad.
Oh my god, there!
He's living.
I hope one person
just replies to me,
I'm winning.
And then,
they always do it
when I'm gone.
And then,
and then,
they clean up immediately
when I get back.
They're, they're,
they're like a fucking system.
They do have a system?
I,
I'm impressed.
Oh, I died.
See, look at them,
look at them.
Oh my god,
they're cleaning up!
Oh my god!
Oh my god,
they're cleaning up
after themselves!
They're so good, right?
They're so cute!
Oh my god!
Don't let the boss run away!
They have such good manners!
I love them!
This is so,
this is so,
what little gentlemen?
What little light?
Like,
oh my god!
I gotta look good for Macy!
You guys are so cute!
Right?
I love my sunflies so much,
they're so cute.
Like legitimately adorable.
I'm so happy you're in good hands.
Me too!
Carol, did I tell you?
Like yesterday,
I was talking membership,
membership,
most membership things are,
are secrets,
but I was like saying that,
how much I'm so grateful for them,
that I feel like I need to like,
volunteer and give back to the world.
No,
that's so fucking real though,
that's so fucking real,
cause same,
I,
fucking same,
like every,
it's bad,
I'll talk about a lot,
about how like grateful I am
for the sweetie buns and shit,
and like I'll gush about them and shit,
like,
I,
I get you,
it's fucking,
it's not, I don't know,
it's just nice to be,
around people who are so,
wonderful,
you know,
so sweet,
and it's so nice to see
how much they love you,
you know,
like,
my god!
They love you!
They're so good!
I'm so happy,
my sunflies.
My sunflies are so good!
Sweetie buns are good too,
like,
honestly,
you make us like philanthropists.
I, I snorted a little,
oops.
Sweetie bun and snippet bun,
so where love letter,
what are the sweetie buns and snippets together?
Snippet bun,
snip bun,
sweet,
bit,
oh yeah!
Sweet bits and love letter,
oh there's a candy inside,
I love letter!
Sorry,
I like shipping things,
do we want to,
just like,
zap some love letters?
Yeah,
here let me change to,
just chatting,
I'm pretty sure.
Senpai!
Oh wait,
it's playing everything again.
Oh,
we're all the way over here,
let me move us.
There we go,
over here!
Get over here!
Senpai!
Let me like,
quit here.
The tackle,
the tackle buns are so cute.
Hold on,
I gotta unlock,
unlock it and then,
Senpai!
Serenity muted,
hold on,
I gotta,
oh no!
She's,
she's drunk off of power!
And I,
you're here,
you're alive now.
Anything I just said,
anything I just said.
What is she saying?
They're debanning.
I wonder,
what could I have said?
I'm easel.
It's our secret,
it's our little secret.
Yeah,
it's our secret,
you can't know our secrets.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
I'm so happy,
I'm so fucking happy right now.
Me too.
I'm sorry,
I'm staring at your tackle yaki hair buns,
they're so good.
The second I saw like,
the little ones,
I was like,
wait,
I know what I can do.
You're like the queen
of finding the cutest assets.
My,
my god.
I love finding assets
to match this tree.
You're so good at it.
I was like,
look at that.
I'll be like,
clip,
clip art.
Transparent,
and then it's never transparent.
I'm getting cozy now.
We're so cozy.
Hold on, let me,
there we go.
There we go.
So we're not coming
being my big ass hair.
Your hair is so huge.
I love it though.
I remember when you were like,
you're like,
I can show the model now.
And I saw it.
And I was like,
I know what I was like finally,
you can see,
you can see my form.
But wait,
it was the worst.
It was the worst
being hidden for so long.
Cause it's like,
I wanna show you everything.
Yeah.
Then when the tree
was on the other foot,
when I,
I was going crazy.
You saw, you saw.
Yeah, I saw.
You were like,
you were making theories
about what I was gonna look like.
Like all you had was
like the silhouette.
I did.
And then you had a very good guess
cause I was like,
okay, well,
I'm gonna give you a hint
about which silhouette I am.
And then you,
you figured out right away.
Cause like,
I don't know.
First off,
it's so clever.
I mean,
all of you guys' designs
are so fun and clever.
Of course,
I have a bias in society.
Everyone is stupid to be cool,
but I have a bias
and that's messy,
messy, messy, messy, messy.
But like,
I love,
I don't wanna say
this one out loud
because
it was gonna be a surprise
for you too,
but I'm really slow
comes to drawing.
I was gonna make
a comic about us.
I give you a little
sweaty
and then you cut it out
so like,
you know,
it's more your style.
I get the draft
of this comic
like the J,
the J,
your design draw.
I love you.
But like,
Do I still,
do I still have,
do I have you?
Hold on.
I do.
I don't know if you'll show up,
but
that's me.
Look at that,
it's me.
It's a me.
Nicely.
My favorite Mario.
Merci.
No, she looks so huggable.
She is.
And I can hug her
right now.
You guys can't.
This is me hugging.
We're hugging.
I promise.
You can't see our arms.
So hugging.
Hugging.
What are you going to do
to keep girls are hugging?
Can't do anything to stop it.
I'm so,
I'm so sorry for teasing.
I'm so sorry for teasing
and being so,
so rude to the boys sometimes.
It's okay.
They deserve it.
I let you
because you have best friend
Braille.
It's just so fun.
Sanity is not sorry.
I'm a little sorry
because you guys are so nice
and cute, you know?
You're so sweet to her.
Right?
They're so kind.
But like because of that,
it's a little fun to be like,
yeah.
You know what it is?
It's because I want to see this
sometimes to reassure you.
That's it.
It's like me reading
a romance story.
I'm like, yeah,
get a little jealous.
Get a little jealous
so that we can go on to
very fancy and be like,
we love you a lot too.
And then you can be like,
yeah, I know sometimes.
And then like,
you know,
you give them a little treat
in the cage.
And then little smooches.
Yeah.
Yeah, they,
they are good.
They are good.
They are great.
Like I love them.
Like legitimately love them.
Like I tell Serenity,
I'm like, I love them.
What the heck?
Like just girly things.
Yeah,
we got gossip about you guys.
I know all the secrets.
She helps me set up the traps too.
The traps in the basement
in case you try to escape.
Come on,
could you imagine the home alone
shit we come across?
Right.
Like,
like at that point,
you're too scared to leave the basement.
You don't know if you're gonna like,
slip on marbles
or like,
oh,
I almost said something terrible.
I'm going to text it to you.
you
You know you are the saw
The saw like breaks and then the cliff falls instead of like those the edge
Honestly
We're so we're so we're so like besties it's so funny
We've known each other for so long and we've like
been
It's like we just clicked instantly
Like I don't know it was just such an instant click of being like wow
She's so cool. I'm like I'm shy as fuck
It was instant click this like we knew each other for years
Oh no
Yeah, and then we've like cheered each other on and then we've like
You know like done events together and stuff
Yeah, and then we've always talked about like meeting each other like IRL and stuff
No, honestly like uh shy as in like we're
We're usually not the we're kind of nervous people when like we're trying to like message first
But then like we're also the type that like open up immediately
Oh, how do we compete with serenity chat?
You don't have to compete because they're not competition
It's because you're my number one she's here to like cheer us on
I'm the cheerleader guys. I'm here be like, yeah some pipe
Kiss the girl do it do it
I
I cannot stress enough. I'm the best friend. I'm the best friend girlie. I'm the girlie. Who's that?
I have you guys not read any yuri or yaoi ever. I'm the best friend girl. All right. No, that's wrong
I've been reading a lot of yuri lately, so I'm putting myself in the stance of the best friend guy
And suffice with the girl and here's the other girl. Listen, I gotta kind of mix up for a moment
I'm not confused but
Point is sometimes you're first for number one. I'm here cheering you guys on I bought you guys to kiss already damn it
I never knew I was a cute girl time to find out today. You're actually all cute girls. Congratulations
Oh
Like
Like honestly like
Serenity is like the best wingman
The best cheerleader
Like especially for us
She cheers me on and like tells me like you just do it girl
Hi
And I love cheering you on are you kidding my favorite fucking activity my favorite activity
Every day is a week. I have every every stream you have on I have you on somewhere be it phone switch
tablet other monitor
I love you but
Yeah
Every cute girl gets a tragic backstory and a little mascot friend
I
You know, you're supposed to like you're like, oh
Mercy mercy, I don't know what to get mercy. I should ask Serenity her best friend
That's it. That's it. Exactly. I'm not competition. Why are you jealous of me? We ain't like that. Are you kidding?
The like, you know, love letter should
fan art would be cute, but like, you know
But it ain't like that
You'll be cute for like, you know, we like that, you know, aren't you some cannon?
Yeah
Okay, I close my eyes any years
No
Okay, okay, I'm good. I'm good. Okay
Can we ask mercy what to get first Serenity?
Yeah, especially if you're a sweetie bun I can help out
No, sorry, I started thinking about your birthday
Yeah
I'm excited for my 15. Did you see my joke where I was like, yeah, Julius scissor
He's dying with me. We both die the same way
I'm totally the reincarnation
Oh my god, wait, wait, I have to find one of those emojis emoji coffee balls those of like, hey sluts
It's too, it's it's the odds of march
If there has to be one
Yes
It's gotta be like Caesar got stabbed. So now you have to get stabbed in the ass
Yeah, oh my god
It's perfect. It's perfect
The rides of March has come
Oh
No, no, no, no silly sometimes at your booty the rides of March has come
So much
I'm coughing so damn much
It's so good
If you have your chin back, you're a glad dickie
How do you pronounce gladiator with dick glad dictator?
It doesn't work. It doesn't work
How am I gonna be a gladiator now? It's okay. Okay. It's okay. Everything will be just fine
Yeah
Hahaha
Like remember when I said to behave for serenity I lied
Serenity to behave
I can't stop her. She's a menace. Oh, where'd you go?
No, get up back here stint pound. Say it with your whole chest
And this is why I love her
Of course
Why else would I I would be I would never stop you from being you
Unless that's unless the you being you was is a danger to yourself
I would never stop you for being you
Break out on my skin. I'm like a fucking creature
I love you girl. I'm just I'm so lucky to have a best friend like you. I'm so lucky to have you
I'm so grateful for you
like
girl
I'm so happy with you right now
Oh, don't we don't know we can get emotional
I'm sorry. No, no, no business business business
This is fucking awesome, you know, like it just feels so great to be together
Like this girl we fucking did it. Yeah, we did
We're fucking crazy. It makes me so happy. This is like shit that like we just always dreamed about, you know
Yes
We were we've we spent like nights all nights like talking about and being like, yes, we're gonna do it. We're gonna get here
We would work hours together. Just like
And then we would review each other's audition video
And then the leading game together
I don't know. It's it's so nice
And I I truly feel like you are you're flourishing here and everyone in BLA has been treating you so good so far
Surprise
No, but I think you're very you're very well suited for VNU as well. You seem so happy
Every time you mess with me, you're like, I got a plan coming. I'm so happy staff is so kind to me
I know I'm always coming up to you like you'll never guess the new thing I'm planning, huh?
I'm like you're crazy friends in the basement another basement just crawling up. You have two basements
One for Senpai's and that one's all nice and then there's the one I'm in where it's like
Have you ever seen Breaking Bad? I haven't but I imagine if he had a basement it'd be like that
It's like you keep mercy on her her toes too. Yeah, well
She she gives me some surprises and stuff, but you know, I love all her surprises
Sometimes you also run by me something saying like do you think this is a good idea? And I'm like, yeah, of course
I gave a little forewarning if I'm just like, maybe it's not a good idea
No, but your fucking advice is so great like you don't like you don't understand like I
I don't think I'd be here without you. Yeah. Well, no, I know for a fact. I wouldn't be here without you. However, come on
Like just
That's like too equitable to too many things, but it's true. I I really wouldn't
I love you I love you too
I'm so happy
This is like our first collab together, which is great. We've been waiting for this role. I was like, when are you free?
We gotta pick a game
God, I know that was the hardest was just picking
It's the hardest is always just picking the one game to play first because it's like
I mean with my fucking crunchy ass cough
Because like there's I open my steam library and I'm just like that would be fun. That would be fun. That would be fun. That would be fun
How soon do you think the next collab will be?
Whenever you're free
I have to set up a schedule for it because I well there are several plans, you know
Mm-hmm
We're both busy girls, but also we're trying our best to find a free time together
We don't get to do as much calls as we used to we used to like be like, okay, let's call
It makes me so I'm happy we text a lot. Yeah, we text a lot
I make me happy because I feel that I know I it's like
Whatever we're both working. It's just it's so high
but like
I'm happy. I'm happy. We at least text and talk talk a lot, you know
I do want to call more though. I miss them. I miss yeah, I miss them too
Yeah, I always text I always text we got each other's phone numbers
I know I know that's my favorite because like sometimes discord is buggy too. So like I like that. I'm just able to like
Like
And then we just text
My phone's right here
Oh, there's so much pressure
Hold on I'm gonna reply. Oh my god. Oh my god guys. Do you think she's gonna reply to me? Do you think she's gonna reply? Oh my god, here we are
I I think it's really funny though because um
Because like so I have a bunch of heart emojis
Seriously? Yeah, I have ears so professionally in my phone
Mine is not mine is not professional mine mine says messy like 50 heart emojis
In parenthesis
Wow
But I've spelled it like how you would say it if you were doing a borat voice
Your name is too long to appear fully in my silence
I do it with everyone and even my mom
Even even the parents even the parents are like super professional looking
It's like first name last name, you know, parentheses mother
Yeah, no, I'm I'm quirky
Even even my family even my family isn't saved normal
My my mom is named mothership
God who's rough during the all collab my mom called me and I think it was rora who likes sighs
She was like
I went on tumblr when I was in high school. It's irreversible. I can't fix anything. This is just who I am now
I
You're so tumblr brain rot. I gave you a quiz. I gave you a quiz and you almost got a hundred percent on it
Like literally I gave her this little quiz like how much tumblr brain rot do you have I gave her the quiz
and then
You almost got a hundred percent and I was like
I like to say I'm a historian. Yeah, I know I'm just brain rotted, but like let me live in denial
I think the only question she didn't get was like this newer newer quote
Hmm
What do you call like a what was it like a sad boy or something?
No, oh, oh, there was one question that was like asking
all like the pathetic wet cat like
um
Films or whatever. Yeah, I didn't I didn't get all of those because like, you know, I know pathetic shopping
Covered in milk, you know
I think it was like the answer was like, you know a sad meow meow or something
Yeah, yeah, it was like sad meow meow and I'm like, I don't I'm so sorry pookie. What the fuck is that?
But otherwise you got like almost a hundred percent on it
God it was bad. It really it was like, yeah, I was like at 85 or something. It was just that question
It was just my pathetic little meow meow, you know
That was so funny
Anyways girl, I think I'm gonna wrap up now because my tummy hearty now
Say, no, I've been laughing so much in all those squats. Are you kidding me? Yeah, they're like hurting now if we're in pain
So I don't know I don't know if you want to say goodbye to senpai's on your own or not
So I will I will I will beat you and do
I love you
I love you so much. Thank you so much for having me on. This is such a blast. This has been such an amazing time
Thank you. No problem. I was we were looking forward to this so much
I know the fucking day you were like
The day you were like, I'm in I'm like, I can't wait to go
Oh
I'm so happy and this is just the start, baby. This is just a fucking start. We're gonna ping pong this all the way through
I can't believe senpai knew I can't believe they've been foreshadowing this whole fucking time, right?
All right, thank you so much for having me on. I love you, mesi. I love you. That's what it's more cool to
I
And now we're together
There we go, he's disconnected
She just sent me a coffee pasta. I love her
Did I have fun? I had lots of fun, but my stomach's hurting
This cough is like pretty pretty heavy right now. I love you. I love you too, serenity
She she's just literally just yeeted herself away. Did you all have fun today senpai? It was super chaotic
My cough is really bad though. So I'm gonna have to fix that. I I I'm I'm thinking that
That it's probably like I'm actually getting sick because I did feel
Earlier that I had like a little bit of a fever
I felt like I did have a little bit of a fever this morning. So it's probably me actually being sick sick
Oh
More than just the takoyaki fever. Yeah, like a fever fever
Oh, I just I was like my my forehead was feeling a little bit warm and mom was like
Mama was like, are you okay? And I'm like, yeah, I think so. I how I feel so bad
I think I was running on adrenaline the entire time
Running on adrenaline just be like I need to see serenity and we're gonna have such a great time together
And I hope
I hope that we all get to hang out again soon
Uh
I don't really have any clothing we we that was that was it. That was it. That was our closing ceremony
If you like serenity, I would really appreciate it if you would all support her as well
She is my darling best friend for like ages
I'm telling you ages
It's it's like it's so fun. It's so fun. I'm so glad we get
To hang out together. Oh it coughs getting really bad. Okay, so I'll let you guys go
I'll let you guys
Uh go, uh because this this cough is pretty bad. So I'll see you again next time. Okay
Screen for mercy
So